over watches next seasonal event may be  coming very soon I'm Tony and this is  your romantic gamespot news update it  looks like overwatch is getting  Valentine's Day content new voice lines  were recently data mined from the game's  public test realm one of these features  mercy offering Genji some chocolates I  got you some chocolates Kenji Swiss  they're the best Thank You Angela  perhaps you could share them with me  romantic fanfictions aside this strongly  hints at a Valentine's Day event for the  game at the very least we should be  getting some new voice lines this would  be over watches fourth seasonal event  after the Summer Games Halloween and  holiday updates so it's certainly a  possibility are there any special  costumes or loot you'd like to see let  me know in the comments or on Twitter at  chain gun hope and for all the latest on  overwatch you're already in the right  place